You know that saying, you can really tell who somebody is in a crisis? You can really tell at Christmas, too. That's because Christmas, more than any other day in the American year, is a day when we're all handed the same stage props. The same tree, the presents, the meal, the relatives, and all the same expectations. And then we all try to create, more or less, the same kind of day. It's like hundreds of millions of people all set to work doing exactly the same art project. And not just any art project, but a very high stakes art project, an art project everybody cares about getting right. And in that setting, the choices people make never seem clearer.
你知道那句老话吗？在危机时刻，你才能真正看清一个人是谁。其实在圣诞节也是如此。因为圣诞节比起美国一年中任何其他日子，都更像是我们每个人都被分发了同样的舞台道具。同样的树、同样的礼物、同样的餐食、同样的亲戚，以及所有同样的期望。然后，我们所有人都在努力创造出大同小异的一天。这就像成千上万的人都在埋头做同一个艺术项目。而且这不仅仅是普通的艺术项目，而是一个赌注极高的项目，每个人都在意把它做好。在这种环境下，人们所做的选择似乎从未如此清晰。
And one place you can witness this human drama at work is at one of the epicenters of modern Christmas, the world's biggest toy store, Toys R Us.
而你亲眼目睹这一人间戏剧上演的地方之一，就是现代圣诞节的震中之一，全球最大的玩具店——玩具反斗城。
Attention shoppers. Attention shoppers. Toys R Us is closed for the evening. Please bring all  your final selections up to the registers at this time.
各位顾客请注意，各位顾客请注意。玩具反斗城今晚即将打烊。请在此时将您最后选购的商品带到收银台。
Closing time, Christmas Eve. But still the store is filled with parents making one last run to the goal line of a perfect Christmas. Mark [? Neimus ?] and his teenage son Ricky are walking the length of the store. Walking, literally, as quickly as men can walk without actually breaking into a run. Their bodies are tense. They spot a sales girl.
平安夜闭店时间。但店内依然挤满了家长，他们正为了完美的圣诞节做最后的一搏。马克·内姆斯和他的十几岁儿子瑞奇正沿着商店走道穿行。他们走得很快，简直快到不跑起来的极限了。他们的身体很紧绷。他们发现了一位售货员。
Do you know where these twins dolls are? They are twins. They're like $70.
你知道这对双胞胎娃娃在哪里吗？是双胞胎。大概70美元。
They're directed into aisle 12C. It is stacked high with dolls. The [? Neimus ?] boys don't have much time. Where are the twin dolls? There's Heart to Heart Baby, whose heart really beats. There is poseable Sleepy Soft Skin. There is Softina, the miracle soft foam doll. There is Baby Bathe-A-Lot. There's Danielle's Fashion Ensemble. There's Baby Braids, the pretty, huggable, fashion hair doll. There is Baby Tummy Talks.
他们被指引到12C通道。那里堆满了娃娃。内姆斯父子没有太多时间。双胞胎娃娃在哪里？有心脏真的会跳的“真心宝宝”。有可摆姿势的“睡眠软皮娃娃”。有奇迹软泡沫娃娃“Softina”。有“爱洗澡宝宝”。有“丹妮尔时尚套装”。有“辫子宝宝”，那个漂亮、可拥抱的时尚发型娃娃。还有“腹语宝宝”。
They are in this aisle somewhere.
它们就在这排货架上的某个地方。
Well, no. Actually, they're not. A middle aged black couple, themselves in the search for a doll called the Sparkle doll, suggests 11C.
嗯，并没有。其实不在。一对中年黑人夫妇正在寻找一款叫“闪亮娃娃”的玩具，他们建议去11C看看。
All the dolls in 11C, for some reason, have names that suggest the names of starlets in adult films. So Shy Sherry, Baby Shivers, Powder Pool twins, Previous Playmate. Debbie Attachable Accessories. Standing there, I realize, of course their names are like names from adult films. Where else do you find this kind of hyped up, packaged, theatrical girlishness?
出于某种原因，11C所有的娃娃名字听起来都像成人电影里的明星。比如“害羞雪莉”、“颤抖宝宝”、“粉末池双胞胎”、“前任玩伴”、“黛比的可拆卸配饰”。站在那儿，我意识到，当然它们的名字听起来像成人电影里的名字。除了这里，你还能在哪里找到这种被大肆炒作、包装、戏剧化的女性化特征？
Right here.
就在这里。
Oh, here they are. OK.
哦，它们在这儿。好了。
They find a price sticker on the twins doll. And they stand there, unnerved.
他们找到了双胞胎娃娃的价格标签。然后他们站在那里，感到不安。
I don't know.
我不知道。
What are you looking at?
你在看什么？
The price.
价格。
It turns out to be $90.
结果是90美元。
Oh, well. I guess I've got to get it.
好吧。我想我得买下它。
Who is it for?
是给谁买的？
It's for my daughter.
给我女儿。
How old is she?
她多大？
She's four. Going to be five.
四岁。快五岁了。
How come so last minute? The store closes in just two minutes.
怎么搞得这么仓促？商店再过两分钟就关门了。
We bought her some other things. And tonight, she asked me three times if Santa was coming. And I said, yes. And she said, good, because he's bringing me these twins. And we didn't have it. I never thought I'd be doing this at 7:30 on Christmas Eve. I've seen it in movies. I swear to God, I never thought I'd be doing this. But here I am.
我们给她买了一些别的东西。但今晚，她问了我三次圣诞老人会不会来。我说会。她说，太好了，因为他会给我带来这对双胞胎。而我们没准备。我从没想过会在平安夜七点半做这种事。我在电影里见过，我发誓，我从没想过我会做这种事。但我现在就在这儿。
Well, I've got to go pay for this now.
好吧，我得去付钱了。
You're a good dad.
你是个好爸爸。
I'd better be, for $90.
最好是，花了90美元呢。
This is the thing about Christmas. Christmas has given him a stage on which he can prove who he is. He's the same good dad he always is, but more so, you know? Christmas. Christmas is the time when everybody is who they normally are, but more so.
这就是圣诞节的真谛。圣诞节给了他一个舞台，让他可以证明自己是谁。他依然是他一贯表现出来的那位好父亲，甚至更多，你懂吗？圣诞节。圣诞节是一个每个人都保持本色，但表现得更加极致的时候。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. If you are hearing our program for the first time, a number of public radio stations around the country are just picking us up for this Christmas special. We are a new public radio show. Each week we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, performers, radio producers to tackle that theme with radio monologues, mini documentaries, overheard conversations, found tape, anything we can think of.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你是第一次收听我们的节目，全国有很多公共广播电台刚刚接入我们的圣诞特辑。我们是一个新的公共广播节目。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、表演者、广播制作人通过广播独白、迷你纪录片、偷听到的对话、现成录音带等任何我们能想到的方式来探讨该主题。
Today's program in three acts. Act One, Toys R Us. Act Two, David Sedaris' "SantaLand Diaries." Act Three, Christmas Freud. That's Sigmund Freud. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，玩具反斗城。第二幕，大卫·塞达里斯的《圣诞乐园日记》。第三幕，圣诞弗洛伊德。那是指西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。请继续收听。
Act Two.
第二幕。
My costume is green. I wear green velvet knickers, a forest green velvet smock, and a perky little hat decorated with spangles. This is my work uniform.
我的服装是绿色的。我穿着绿色天鹅绒灯笼裤，一件森林绿天鹅绒罩衫，还有一顶装饰着亮片的俏皮小帽子。这就是我的工作制服。
Four Christmases ago, those were the words which introduced radio listeners across the country to David Sedaris. His account of working as a department store elf for two Christmas seasons was immediately one of the most popular stories ever broadcast on National Public Radio's Morning Edition. Only the coverage of commentator Red Barber's death generated more tape requests, I have been told. It is with pleasure that we broadcast it again today. The Morning Edition version of "The SantaLand Diaries" ran only eight and a half minutes because of the format of Morning Edition. But here, here we have the time to stretch out, and play you something that's much closer to David's original text.
四年前的圣诞节，正是这些话向全国的广播听众介绍了大卫·塞达里斯。他关于在百货公司担任圣诞精灵两个圣诞季的经历，立刻成为了美国国家公共电台《早间版》播出过的最受欢迎的故事之一。据我所知，只有关于评论员雷德·巴伯去世的报道引发了更多的录音带索求。我们很高兴今天再次播出。因为《早间版》的格式限制，《圣诞乐园日记》的版本只播了八分半钟。但在这里，我们有时间展开讲，为你播放一些更接近大卫原文的内容。
I was in a coffee shop reading the want-ads when I saw, "Macy's Herald Square, the largest store in the world, has big opportunities for outgoing, fun-loving people of all shapes and sizes. Working as an elf in Macy's SantaLand means being at the center of the excitement." I brought the ad home and my roommate, Rusty, and I were laughing about it. And he dared me to call for an interview. So I did.
当时我正在咖啡店读招聘启事，看到上面写着：“梅西百货先驱广场店，世界上最大的商店，为所有体型、外向且热爱生活的人提供巨大的机会。作为梅西圣诞乐园的精灵，意味着处于兴奋的中心。”我把广告带回家，我和室友拉斯蒂一起嘲笑它。他激我打个电话去面试。于是我照做了。
The woman at Macy's asked, "Would you be interested in full-time elf or evening and weekend elf?" I said, "Full-time elf."
梅西百货的女士问：“你对全职精灵还是晚间和周末精灵感兴趣？”我说：“全职精灵。”
I am a 33-year-old man applying for a job as an elf. I often see people in the streets dressed as objects and handing out leaflets. I usually avoid leaflets, but it breaks my heart to see a grown man dressed as a taco. So if there is a costume involved, I tend to not only accept the leaflet, but to accept it graciously, saying, "thank you so much," and thinking, "you poor son of a bitch."
我是一个33岁的男人，正在申请做一名精灵。我经常在街上看到人们打扮成各种物品并分发传单。我通常会避开传单，但看到一个成年男人打扮成一个塔可饼，这真让我心碎。所以如果涉及到化妆，我倾向于不仅接受传单，而且会礼貌地接受，说“太感谢了”，心里想着，“你这可怜的混蛋。”
This afternoon on Lexington Avenue, I accepted a leaflet from a man dressed as a camcorder. Hot dogs, tacos, video cameras, these things make me sad because there's no place for them, no community. They don't fit in on the streets.
今天下午在莱克星顿大道上，我接受了一位打扮成摄像机的男人的传单。热狗、塔可饼、摄像机，这些东西让我难过，因为它们没有归属感，没有社区。它们不适合出现在大街上。
I figure that at least as an elf I will have a place. I'll be in Santa's Village with all the other elves. We'll live in a fluffy wonderland, surrounded by candy canes and gingerbread shacks. It won't be quite as sad as being some big French fry out on a street corner.
我想，至少作为一名精灵，我会有归属感。我将待在圣诞老人的村庄，和其他精灵在一起。我们将生活在一个毛茸茸的奇境中，被拐杖糖和姜饼小屋所环绕。这不会像在街角当一块大炸薯条那样悲惨。
I have to admit that I had high hopes when moving to New York. In my imagination, I went straight from Penn Station to the offices of One Life to Live. In my imagination, I went out for drinks with Cord Roberts and Victoria Buchanan, the show's biggest stars. We'd sit in a plush booth at a Tony Cocktail Lounge and they'd lift their frosty glasses in my direction and say, "A toast to David Sedaris, the best writer this show ever had." I'd say, "You guys, cut it out."
我必须承认，搬到纽约时我曾抱有很高的期望。在我的想象中，我直接从宾夕法尼亚车站去了《只此一生》的办公室。在我的想象中，我和该剧最大的明星科德·罗伯茨和维多利亚·布坎南一起去喝酒。我们坐在托尼鸡尾酒吧的豪华卡座里，他们会朝我举起结霜的杯子说：“为大卫·塞达里斯干杯，这是本剧拥有过的最好的编剧。”我会说：“你们别这样。”
People at the surrounding tables would stare at us, whispering, "Isn't that? Isn't that?" I might be distracted by their enthusiasm. And Victoria Buchanan would lay her hand over mine and tell me that I'd better get used to being the center of the attention.
周围桌子的人会盯着我们，窃窃私语，“那是……那是吗？”我可能会被他们的热情分心。而维多利亚·布坎南会把她的手放在我的手上，告诉我最好习惯成为关注的中心。
But instead, I'm applying for a job as an elf. Instead, someone will say, "What's that shoe size again?" and hand me a pair of seven and a half slippers, the toes of which curl to a point. Even worse is the very real possibility that I will not be hired, that I couldn't even find work as an elf. That's when you know you're a failure.
但相反，我正在申请做一名精灵。相反，有人会说，“那双鞋的尺码是多少？”然后递给我一双七码半的拖鞋，鞋尖向上翘。更糟糕的是，我很有可能根本不会被录用，甚至找不到做精灵的工作。那才是你意识到自己是个失败者的时候。
This afternoon, I sat in the eighth floor SantaLand office, and was told, "Congratulations, Mr. Sedaris. You're an elf." In order to become an elf, I filled out 10 pages worth of forms, took a multiple choice personality test, underwent two interviews, and submitted urine for a drug test.
今天下午，我坐在八楼的圣诞乐园办公室，被告知：“恭喜你，塞达里斯先生。你是一名精灵了。”为了成为一名精灵，我填写了10页的表格，参加了多项选择性格测试，进行了两次面试，并提交了尿样进行药物测试。
During the second interview, we were asked why we wanted to be elves, which, when you think about it, is a fairly tough question. I told the interviewers that I wanted to be an elf because it was the most ridiculous thing I'd ever heard of. I figured that, for once in my life, I would be completely honest and see how far it got me. I failed the drug test. My urine had roaches and stems floating in it, but still they hired me, and honesty had nothing to do with it. They hired me because I'm short. Everyone they hired is short. I am one of the taller elves.
在第二次面试中，我们被问到为什么想做精灵，当你仔细想想，这是一个相当棘手的问题。我告诉面试官，我想做精灵是因为这是我听过的最荒唐的事情。我想，平生第一次，我要完全诚实，看看这能让我走多远。我没通过药物测试。我的尿液里漂浮着碎屑和茎干，但他们还是录用了我，这与诚实毫无关系。他们录用我只是因为我个子矮。他们录用的每个人个子都很矮。我是比较高的精灵之一。
I have spent the last several days sitting in a crowded, windowless Macy's classroom, undergoing the first phases of elf training. We have been addressed by all sorts of instructors, who begin their presentations by saying, "This looks like an outstanding group of elves." Several of the bosses have led us in motivational cheers, a concept which stuns me to the core.
过去几天我一直坐在梅西百货拥挤、没有窗户的教室里，接受精灵培训的第一阶段。各种讲师向我们发表讲话，他们以“这看起来是一群杰出的精灵”作为开场白。几位老板带领我们进行了励志欢呼，这个概念让我从心底感到震惊。
Following an eight hour day of cash register training, we were treated to a video presentation by the security staff, visited by interpreters for the deaf, and presented with "The Elfin Guide," a 40-page booklet of rules and regulations. This afternoon's training concluded with a tour of SantaLand.
在完成了八小时的收银机培训后，我们观看了保安人员的录像演示，接待了聋哑人翻译，并获赠了《精灵指南》，这是一本40页的规则手册。今天下午的培训以参观圣诞乐园结束。
SantaLand is beautiful. It really is. It's a wonderland with 10,000 twinkling lights and diversions. People enter and walk through a maze, which affords views of mechanical dancing penguins, train sets, spinning bears, and really big candy canes. They walk through a quarter mile of maze and wind up  at the Magic Tree, at which point they brace themselves for Santa.
圣诞乐园很美。真的。这是一个拥有10,000盏闪烁灯光和各种消遣的仙境。人们进来后穿过一个迷宫，可以看到机械跳舞的企鹅、火车模型、旋转的熊和巨大的拐杖糖。他们走过四分之一英里的迷宫，最终到达魔法树，在那里，他们为迎接圣诞老人做好准备。
The tree is a tunnel designed to resemble a complex system of roots. The child is supposed to think, "I can't believe I'm inside a tree." But instead, I think it looks like a large scientific model of the human intestinal tract.
那棵树是一个设计成类似于复杂的根系系统的隧道。孩子本该想：“我不敢相信我在树里面。”但相反，我觉得它看起来像一个巨大的人体肠道科学模型。
Once you pass the Magic Tree, the lights dim. It is dark beyond that tree. It is dark because Macy's does not want people to know that there are six houses. Macy's wants people to think that there is only one house, and one Santa, and he lives at Macy's.
一旦你穿过魔法树，灯光就会变暗。树后面很黑。那是因为梅西百货不想让人们知道那里有六个房子。梅西百货希望人们认为只有一个房子，一个圣诞老人，他就住在梅西百货。
They constantly refer to the movie Miracle on 34th Street. But even if someone believed in one Santa, why would they believe he lived in a department store? Nobody lives in a department store. The Santa houses are cozy and intimate, laden with toys. Each house has a hidden camera.
他们不断提及电影《34街的奇迹》。但即使有人相信只有一个圣诞老人，为什么会相信他住在一间百货公司里？没人住在百货公司里。圣诞老人的房子舒适亲密，堆满了玩具。每个房子里都有一个隐藏的摄像头。
This afternoon, we learn the names of the various elf positions. You can be, for example, an Oh My God Elf, and stand at the corner near the escalator. People arrive, see the long line around the corner, and say, "Oh, my god." And your job is to tell them that it won't take more than an hour to see Santa. You can be an Entrance Elf, a Water Cooler Elf, a Bridge Elf, Train Elf, Maze Elf, Island Elf, Magic Window Elf, Emergency Exit Elf, Counter Elf, Magic Tree Elf, Pointer Elf, Santa Elf, Photo Elf, Usher Elf, Cash Register Elf, or Exit Elf.
今天下午，我们学习了各种精灵职位的名称。例如，你可以成为“天哪精灵”，站在自动扶梯附近的角落。人们到达后，看到拐角处排长队，会说：“天哪。”你的工作就是告诉他们见圣诞老人不会超过一小时。你可以成为入口精灵、饮水机精灵、桥梁精灵、火车精灵、迷宫精灵、岛屿精灵、魔窗精灵、紧急出口精灵、柜台精灵、魔法树精灵、指向精灵、圣诞老人精灵、拍照精灵、领位精灵、收银精灵或出口精灵。
We were given a demonstration of various positions in action, acted out by returning elves who were so on stage and goofy that it made me a little sick to my stomach. I don't know that I could look anyone in the eye and exclaim, "Oh, my goodness! I think I see Santa!" Or "Can you close your eyes and make a very special Christmas wish?" Everything these elves say seems to have an exclamation point on the end of it. It makes one's mouth hurt to speak with such forced merriment. It embarrasses me to hear people talk this way.
我们观看了各种职位的演示，由老精灵们表演，他们表演得如此夸张和做作，让我有点胃里翻腾。我不知道我是否能看着别人的眼睛惊呼：“噢，我的天！我想我看到了圣诞老人！”或者“你能闭上眼睛许一个特别的圣诞愿望吗？”这些精灵说的一切似乎都在句末带有一个感叹号。用那种强作欢笑的语气说话会让人的嘴巴感到疼痛。听到人们这样说话让我感到尴尬。
I prefer being frank with children. I'm more likely to say, "You must be exhausted," or "I know a lot of people who would kill for that little waistline of yours." I'm afraid I won't be able to provide the enthusiasm Santa is asking for. I think I'll be a low-key sort of elf.
我更喜欢对孩子坦诚。我更有可能说，“你一定累坏了，”或者“我知道很多人会为你的那个小细腰而疯狂。”恐怕我无法提供圣诞老人所要求的那种热情。我想我会做一个低调的精灵。
Today was elf dress rehearsal. The lockers and dressing rooms are on the eighth floor, directly behind SantaLand. People have gotten to know one another over the past four days of training. But once we took off our clothes and put on our costumes, everything changed. Ivy, the woman in charge of costuming, handed out our uniforms, and gave us a lecture on keeping things clean. She held up a calendar and said, "Ladies, you know what this is. Use it. I have scraped enough blood out from the crotches of elf knickers to last me the rest of my life. And don't tell me, 'I don't wear underpants. I'm a dancer.' You're not a dancer. If you were a real dancer, you wouldn't be here. You're an elf, and you're going to wear panties like an elf."
今天是精灵彩排日。储物柜和更衣室在八楼，就在圣诞乐园后面。过去四天的培训中，大家已经互相认识了。但当我们脱下衣服换上戏服后，一切都变了。负责服装的艾薇分发了我们的制服，并就保持清洁对我们训话。她举起一个日历说：“女士们，你们知道这是什么。用它吧。我从精灵灯笼裤的裆部刮下来的血已经够我受用余生的了。别跟我说，‘我不穿内裤。我是舞者。’你不是舞者。如果你是真正的舞者，你不会在这里。你是一名精灵，你得像个精灵一样穿内裤。”
My costume is green. I wear green velvet knickers, a forest green velvet smock, and a perky little hat decorated with spangles. This is my work uniform.
我的服装是绿色的。我穿着绿色天鹅绒灯笼裤，一件森林绿天鹅绒罩衫，还有一顶装饰着亮片的俏皮小帽子。这就是我的工作制服。
During dress rehearsal, I worked as a Santa Elf for house number two. A Santa Elf greets children at the Magic Tree and leads them to Santa's house. When you work as a Santa Elf, you have to go by your elf name. My elf name is Crumpet. The other elves have names like Jingle and Frosty. They take the children by the hand and squeal with forced delight. They sing and prance and behave like cartoon characters come to life. It frightens me.
在彩排期间，我在二号房担任圣诞老人精灵。圣诞老人精灵在魔法树前迎接孩子，并把他们带到圣诞老人的房子。当你担任圣诞老人精灵时，必须使用你的精灵名。我的精灵名是“松饼”。其他精灵的名字叫“叮当”和“霜冻”。他们拉着孩子的手，发出强作欢笑的尖叫声。他们唱歌、跳跃，表现得像活过来的卡通人物。这让我感到恐惧。
Today was the official opening day of SantaLand, and I worked as a Magic Window Elf, a Santa Elf, and an Usher Elf. The Magic Window is located in the adult quick peep line. My job was to say, "Step on the magic star, and look through the window, and you can see Santa." I was at the Magic Window for 15 minutes before a man approached me and said, "You look so stupid."
今天是圣诞乐园正式开业的日子，我担任了魔窗精灵、圣诞老人精灵和领位精灵。魔窗位于成人快速观看队伍中。我的工作是说：“踏上魔法星，透过窗户看，你就能看到圣诞老人。”我在魔窗前待了15分钟，一个男人走近我对我说：“你看上去真蠢。”
I have to admit that he had a point. But still, I wanted to say that at least I get paid to look stupid, that he gives it away for free. But I can't say things like that because I'm supposed to be merry. So instead, I said, "Thank you." Thank you, as if I had misunderstood and thought he had said, "You look terrific." Thank you.
我必须承认他说的有道理。但即便如此，我想说的是，至少我拿报酬看起来很蠢，而他则是免费展示。但我不能那样说，因为我本该是快乐的。所以我说：“谢谢。”谢谢，就好像我误听了，以为他说的是“你看上去好极了”。谢谢。
He was a brawny, wiseguy, wearing a vinyl jacket and carrying a bag from the Radio Shack. I should have said, real loud, "Sorry, man, I don't date other guys." People would have turned and looked our way. And he would have curled into a little ball and died.
他是一个肌肉发达的聪明人，穿着乙烯基夹克，拎着一个Radio Shack的包。我本该大声说：“抱歉，哥们，我不和男人约会。”人们会转过身来看我们。他会缩成一团死掉。
All the Santas have different routines. Some want the children's names. So as you're leading the youngsters from the Magic Tree, you say, "What was your name again? It's right on the tip of my mind where I can't get at it." Then they say their name. And you say, "That's right. Van. You're Van. See, I didn't recognize you with that turtleneck. That's new, isn't it?" And it's always new, because they grow so fast they are always needing larger clothes.
所有的圣诞老人都有不同的套路。有些人想要孩子的名字。所以当你把孩子们从魔法树带过来时，你会说：“你叫什么名字来着？就在我嘴边，但我怎么也想不起来。”然后他们说出名字。你说：“对了。凡。你是凡。你看，你穿上那件高领毛衣我都没认出你来。那是新的，对吧？”而且总是新的，因为他们长得太快，总是需要更大的衣服。
Then you lead them to Santa's door and say, "Let me just check and see if he's ready." And you poke your head in and whisper, "Van." Then, half the time you'll usher the child into the house, and Santa will say, "Stan, it's so good to see you." It's hard when you have three or four kids in a group. It's hard to keep the names straight. And some of the names are names I've never heard. Vaneesha, Fohntaj, Great. A child named Great. I'm Great. That's a name which is bound to prove challenging once he gets old enough to start sleeping around.
然后你把他们领到圣诞老人的门口说：“让我确认一下他准备好了没。”然后你探头进去低声说：“凡。”然后，有一半的时间你会把孩子领进屋，圣诞老人会说：“斯坦，见到你真高兴。”当你有一组三四个孩子时很难。很难记住名字。有些名字我闻所未闻。Vaneesha，Fohntaj，Great。一个名叫“伟大”（Great）的孩子。我是伟大。等他年纪大了开始乱搞男女关系时，这个名字注定会带来挑战。
This afternoon, I was Photo Elf for Santa Howard. Santa Howard uses names, and sits the kids on his lap, and asks if they've been good and what they want for Christmas. And then he asks what they plan to leave him on Christmas Eve. And they say, cookies and milk. And he asks, what kind of cookies? And they say, chocolate chip, or whatever. And he demands the Photo Elf to say, "Chocolate chip? That is Santa's favorite kind of cookie." I don't mind saying it, but I must have said it 60 times today.
今天下午，我是霍华德圣诞老人的拍照精灵。霍华德圣诞老人会叫名字，让孩子们坐在他的膝盖上，问他们是否乖，想要什么圣诞礼物。然后他会问他们打算在平安夜留给他什么。他们说，饼干和牛奶。他问，什么饼干？他们说，巧克力碎饼干之类的。他会要求拍照精灵说：“巧克力碎？那是圣诞老人最喜欢的饼干。”我不介意说，但我今天肯定说了60遍了。
This afternoon, Santa Howard got an Asian child who wasn't familiar with the idea of leaving cookies. Santa asked what she was going to leave him to eat. And she got a puzzled look on her face. He said, "Something round to eat?" And she said, "A potato?"
今天下午，霍华德圣诞老人接待了一个不熟悉留下饼干概念的亚洲孩子。圣诞老人问她打算留给他吃什么。她一脸困惑。他说：“圆圆的能吃的东西？”她说：“土豆？”
22,000 people came to see Santa today, and not all of them were well-behaved. Today I witnessed fistfights and vomiting and magnificent tantrums. Once the line gets long, we break it into four different lines, because anyone in their right mind would leave if they knew it would take over two hours to see Santa. Two hours. You could see a movie in two hours. Standing in a two-hour line makes people worry that they're not living in a democratic nation.
今天有22,000人来看圣诞老人，并不是所有人都守规矩。今天我目睹了拳打脚踢、呕吐和惊人的发脾气。一旦队伍变长，我们就会把它分成四条不同的队伍，因为任何神志正常的人如果知道要花两个多小时才能见到圣诞老人，都会离开。两个小时。你可以看两小时电影。站在两小时的队伍里会让人们担心他们是否生活在一个民主国家。
I was sent into the hallway to direct the second phase of the line. The hallway was packed with people, and all of them seemed to stop me with a question. Which way to the down escalator? Which way to the elevator? The patio restaurant, gift wrap, the women's restroom, Trim-a-Tree.
我被派往走廊指挥第二阶段的队伍。走廊里挤满了人，每个人似乎都停下来问我问题。去下行自动扶梯怎么走？去电梯怎么走？露台餐厅、礼品包装、女洗手间、装饰树在哪？
There was a line for Santa and a line for the women's bathroom. And one woman, after asking me 1,000 questions already, asked, which is the line for the women's bathroom? And I shouted that I thought it was the line with all the women in it. And she said, I'm going to have you fired.
有一条队伍是看圣诞老人的，一条是排女厕所的。一个女人在问了我1000个问题后，问，哪条是女厕所的队伍？我大声说我觉得那条挤满女人的就是。她说，我要让你被开除。
I had two people say that to me today. I'm going to have you fired. Go ahead. Be my guest. I'm wearing a green velvet costume. It doesn't get any worse than this. Who do these people think they are? I'm going to have you fired. And I want to lean over and say, I'm going to have you killed.
今天有两个人对我这么说。我要让你被开除。去吧。请便。我穿着绿色天鹅绒戏服。再糟糕也不过如此了。这些人以为自己是谁？我要让你被开除。我想俯身说，我要让你被杀掉。
This morning, I got stuck at the Magic Window, which is really boring. I'm supposed to stand around and say, "Step on the magic star and you can see Santa." I said that for a while. And then I started saying, "Step on the magic star and you can see Cher." And people got excited. So I said, "Step on the magic star and you can see Mike Tyson." Some people in the other line, the line to sit on Santa's lap, got excited and cut through the gate so that they could stand on my magic star. Then they got angry when they looked through the Magic Window and saw Santa, rather than Cher or Mike Tyson.
今天早上，我被困在魔窗，真的很无聊。我本来应该站着说：“踏上魔法星，你就能看到圣诞老人。”我说了好一阵子。然后我开始说：“踏上魔法星，你就能看到雪儿。”人们兴奋起来。所以我说：“踏上魔法星，你就能看到迈克·泰森。”另一条队伍（排队坐在圣诞老人膝盖上的那条）里的一些人兴奋起来，翻过栅栏，这样他们就能站在我的魔法星上。然后当他们透过魔窗看到的是圣诞老人而不是雪儿或迈克·泰森时，他们生气了。
But what did they honestly expect? Is Cher so hard up for money that she would agree to stand behind a two way mirror at Macy's? The angry people must have said something to management, because I was taken off the Magic Star and sent to Elf Island, which is really boring, because all you do is stand around and act merry.
但他们真正期待的是什么？雪儿真的缺钱到会同意站在梅西百货的双面镜后面吗？那些生气的人一定向管理层反映了，因为我被从魔法星撤下，送到了精灵岛，那里真的很无聊，因为你所做的就是站着表现得很快乐。
At noon, a large group of retarded people came to visit Santa and passed me on my little island. These people were profoundly retarded. They were rolling their eyes and wagging their tongues and staggering towards Santa. It was a large group of retarded people and, after seeing them for 15 minutes, I could not begin to guess where the retarded people ended and the regular New Yorkers began. Everyone looks retarded once you've set your mind to it.
中午，一大群智障人士来看圣诞老人，经过我的小岛。这些人严重智力低下。他们翻着白眼，摇着舌头，摇摇晃晃地朝圣诞老人走去。那是一大群智障人士，在看了他们15分钟后，我无法分辨哪里是智障人士的终点，哪里是普通纽约人的起点。当你存心去想时，每个人看起来都像智障。
This morning, I worked as an Exit Elf, telling people in a loud voice, "This way out of SantaLand." A woman was standing at one of the cash registers paying for her pictures while her son lay beneath her, kicking and heaving, having a tantrum. The woman said, "Riley, if you don't start behaving yourself, Santa is not going to bring you any of those toys you asked for." The child said, "He is too going to bring me toys, liar. He already told me."
今天早上，我担任出口精灵，大声告诉人们：“这是离开圣诞乐园的路。”一个女人站在收银台付照片钱，她的儿子躺在她脚下，又踢又闹，发着脾气。女人说：“莱利，如果你再不乖一点，圣诞老人就不会给你带来你要求的那些玩具了。”孩子说：“他会带给我的，骗子。他已经告诉过我了。”
The woman grabbed my arm and said, "You there, elf. Tell Riley here that if he doesn't start behaving immediately, then Santa is going to change his mind and bring him coal for Christmas." I said that Santa changed his policy and no longer traffics in coal. Instead, if you're bad, he comes to your house and steals things. I told Riley that if he didn't behave himself, Santa was going to take away his TV and all his electrical appliances and leave him in the dark. All your appliances, Riley, including the refrigerator. Your food is going to spoil and smell bad. It is going to be so cold and dark where you are. You're going to wish you never even heard the name Santa.
那个女人抓住我的手臂说：“你，精灵。告诉莱利，如果他不立即变乖，圣诞老人就会改变主意，在圣诞节给他带来煤炭。”我说圣诞老人改变了政策，不再运送煤炭。相反，如果你表现不好，他会去你家偷东西。我告诉莱利，如果他不听话，圣诞老人会拿走他的电视机和所有家用电器，把他留在黑暗中。你所有的电器，莱利，包括冰箱。你的食物会腐烂变臭。你所在的地方会变得又冷又黑。你会后悔从未听说过圣诞老人这个名字。
The woman got a worried look on her face and said, "All right. That's enough." I said, "He's going to take your car and your furniture and all of your towels and blankets and leave you with nothing." The mother said, "No, that's enough. Really."
那个女人脸上露出了担忧的表情，说：“好了。够了。”我说：“他会拿走你的车和家具，还有你所有的毛巾和毯子，让你一无所有。”母亲说：“不，够了。真的。”
Two New Jersey families came today to see Santa. Two loud, ugly husbands with two wives and four children between them. The children gathered around Santa and had their pictures taken. When Santa asked the 1o-year-old boy what he wanted for Christmas, his father shouted, "A woman. Get him a woman, Santa." These men were very loud and irritating, constantly laughing and jostling one another. The two women sat on Santa's lap and had their pictures taken, and each asked Santa for a KitchenAid brand dishwasher and a decent winter coat.
今天有两户新泽西州的家庭来看圣诞老人。两个大声、丑陋的丈夫，带着两个妻子和四个孩子。孩子们围在圣诞老人身边拍照。当圣诞老人问那个10岁的男孩想要什么圣诞礼物时，他父亲大喊：“一个女人。给他找个女人，圣诞老人。”这些男人非常吵闹且惹人厌，不停地大笑和推搡。那两个女人坐在圣诞老人的膝盖上拍照，每个人都向圣诞老人要一台KitchenAid牌洗碗机和一件像样的冬装外套。
Then the husbands sat on Santa's lap. And when asked what he wanted for Christmas, one of the men yelled, "I want a broad with big jugs." The man's small-breasted wife crossed her arms over her chest, looked at the floor, and gritted her teeth. The man's son tried to laugh.
然后丈夫们坐在圣诞老人的膝盖上。当被问到想要什么圣诞礼物时，其中一个男人吼道：“我想要个大胸的荡妇。”那个平胸的妻子双臂交叉在胸前，看着地板，咬紧牙关。男人的儿子试图笑出来。
"Hi. Hello. How are you doing tonight? What are you up to tonight? What are you drinking? I think I'll have whatever you're having. I could use a change."
“嗨。你好。今晚怎么样？今晚在做什么？喝什么呢？我想喝和你一样的。我需要换换口味。”
My roommate, Rusty, gave me these lines. I don't have any idea what to say to people in clubs and bars. I freeze up and wither away. But Rusty tells me that these lines work.
我的室友拉斯蒂给了我这些台词。我不知道在俱乐部和酒吧该跟人说什么。我总是僵住然后萎缩。但拉斯蒂告诉我这些台词管用。
"Hi there. I was just standing across the room, but couldn't help but notice that your glass is empty. Can I buy you a drink? I think I'll have whatever you're having."
“嗨。我刚才站在房间另一边，但忍不住注意到你的杯子空了。能请你喝一杯吗？我想喝和你一样的。”
This evening I was a Maze Elf. Nothing is more boring than being a Maze Elf. Other Maze Elves address children and ask, "What do you want for Christmas?" But really, why should a child tell an elf? Santa is who they've come to see. And it seems pathetic for an elf to try to outshine Santa. After children have passed the dancing penguins, they don't care if they ever see another elf as long as they live. The maze is overpopulated with elves.
今晚我当了迷宫精灵。没有什么比当迷宫精灵更无聊的了。其他迷宫精灵会跟孩子说话，问“你圣诞节想要什么？”但说真的，孩子为什么要告诉精灵？他们是来看圣诞老人的。精灵试图抢圣诞老人的风头显得很可悲。孩子们经过跳舞的企鹅后，根本不在乎这辈子还能不能再见到另一个精灵。迷宫里精灵泛滥。
This evening, I was stationed in the maze near the candy canes. Children would pass, bored. And I'd say, How are you doing tonight? What are you up to this evening? Good. I'll have whatever you're having. Terrific.
今晚，我被分配在迷宫里靠近拐杖糖的地方。孩子们无聊地经过。我说，今晚怎么样？今晚在做什么？很好。我想喝和你一样的。太棒了。
I've met elves from all walks of life. The recession has hit New York very hard. Most of the other elves are show business people, but several of them had real jobs at advertising agencies and brokerage firms. Bless their hearts. These people never in their wildest dreams figured there was a velvet costume waiting in their future. They are the really bitter elves. Most of the elves are young, high school and college students. They're young and they're cute, and one of the job perks is that I get to see these people in their underpants.
我见过各行各业的精灵。经济衰退对纽约打击很大。大多数其他精灵是演艺界人士，但其中几个人在广告公司和经纪公司有正式工作。上帝保佑他们。这些人做梦也没想到他们的未来里还有一套天鹅绒服装在等着他们。他们是那种真正痛苦的精灵。大多数精灵是年轻人、高中生和大学生。他们年轻又可爱，工作福利之一就是我能看到这些人穿内裤的样子。
The overall cutest elf is a fellow from Queens named Richie. His elf name is Snowball, and he tends to ham it up with the children, sometimes tumbling down the path to Santa's house. I generally gag when elves get that cute, but Snowball is hands-down adorable. You want to put him in your pocket.
总体来说最可爱的精灵是一个来自皇后区的家伙，名叫里奇。他的精灵名是“雪球”，他倾向于跟孩子们胡闹，有时会跌跌撞撞地滚向圣诞老人的房子。一般这种精灵可爱到让我作呕，但雪球确实无可挑剔地讨人喜欢。你想把他装进口袋里。
Yesterday, Snowball and I worked as Santa Elves and I got excited when he started saying things like, "I'd follow you to Santa's house any day, Crumpet." It made me dizzy, this flirtation. By mid-afternoon, I was running into walls. By late afternoon, Snowball had cooled down. By the end of our shift, we were in the bathroom changing our clothes, and all of the sudden we were surrounded by five Santas and three other elves. All of them were guys that Snowball had been flirting with. Snowball just leads elves on, elves and Santas.
昨天，雪球和我担任圣诞老人精灵，当他开始说“松饼，我随时愿意跟着你去圣诞老人的房子”时，我兴奋了。这种调情让我头晕目眩。下午，我撞在墙上。傍晚时分，雪球冷静下来了。换班结束时，我们在洗手间换衣服，突然我们被五个圣诞老人和三个其他精灵包围了。他们都是雪球调情过的家伙。雪球就是会钓着精灵，精灵和圣诞老人。
Later on, we were in the elevator and I heard him say to his friend, "I don't know what these guys all want with me. It gives me the creeps, the way they stare." Snowball is playing a dangerous game. It's one thing to get a child fired up, but you really don't want to be working under a jilted Santa.
后来，我们在电梯里，我听到他对朋友说：“我不知道这些人想从我这儿得到什么。这让我毛骨悚然，他们那种盯着我看的方式。”雪球在玩一场危险的游戏。让一个孩子兴奋是一回事，但你绝不想在一个被抛弃的圣诞老人手下工作。
More of David Sedaris' "SantaLand Diaries" and Christmas Freud, in a minute, when our program continues.
稍后为您带来更多大卫·塞达里斯的《圣诞乐园日记》和圣诞弗洛伊德，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. The special Christmas edition of our program. We continue with David Sedaris' "SantaLand Diaries."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目的特别圣诞版。我们继续大卫·塞达里斯的《圣诞乐园日记》。
Out of all the Santas, two are black. And both are so light-skinned that, with a beard and makeup, you'd never know they weren't white. Yesterday, a black woman got upset after, having requested a Santa of color, she was sent to Will. "He's not black," the woman said. We assured the woman that, yes, he was black. And the woman said, "Well, he isn't black enough."
在所有的圣诞老人中，有两个是黑人。而且两人的肤色都非常浅，加上胡子和化妆，你根本不知道他们不是白人。昨天，一位黑人妇女在要求一位有色人种圣诞老人后，被派到了威尔那里，结果她很不高兴。“他不是黑人，”那个女人说。我们向她保证，是的，他是黑人。那个女人说：“好吧，他不够黑。”
Will is a difficult Santa, moody and unpredictable. He spends a lot of time staring off into space. When a boss tells Will that we need to speed things up, Will gets defensive and says, "Listen, I'm playing a role here. Do you understand? A dramatic role that takes a great deal of preparation."
威尔是个难搞的圣诞老人，情绪化且不可预测。他花很多时间发呆。当老板告诉威尔我们需要加快速度时，威尔会防御性地说：“听着，我在这里扮演一个角色。明白吗？一个戏剧性角色，需要大量的准备工作。”
I was the Pointer Elf this afternoon when a woman approached me and whispered, "We would like a traditional Santa. I'm sure you know what I'm talking about." I sent her to Will.
今天下午我担任指向精灵时，一个女人走近我低声说：“我们想要一个传统的圣诞老人。我相信你知道我在说什么。”我把她送到了威尔那里。
Last Saturday, Snowball was the Pointer and a woman said, "Last year we had a chocolate Santa. Make sure it doesn't happen again." Snowball sent her to Will.
上周六，雪球是指向精灵，一个女人说：“去年我们有个巧克力色圣诞老人。确保这种情况别再发生。”雪球把她送到了威尔那里。
I spent time at the Magic Window with an elf named Rita, a dancer who was in the process of making a video with her all-girl singing group. We talked about one thing and another, and she told me that she has appeared on a few soap operas. I asked if she had done One Life to Live and she said, yes. She had had a bit part as a flamenco dancer two years ago when Cord and Tina remarried and had their honeymoon in Madrid.
我在魔窗和一位叫丽塔的精灵待在一起，她是个舞者，正在制作她全女子歌唱组合的录像带。我们聊东聊西，她告诉我她出演过几部肥皂剧。我问她是否演过《只此一生》，她说演过。两年前科德和蒂娜再婚并在马德里度蜜月时，她演过一个小角色，饰演一名弗拉门戈舞者。
And suddenly, I remembered Rita perfectly. I remember Cord and Tina's honeymoon like it was yesterday. Rita wore a red, lacy flamenco dress and stomped around the shiny nightclub floor, while Spain's greatest bullfighter challenged Cord to a duel. Rita said to Cord, "Don't do it, Senor. You would be a fool to fight with Spain's greatest bullfighter."
突然，我完美地记起了丽塔。我记得科德和蒂娜的蜜月就像昨天一样。丽塔穿着红色的蕾丝弗拉门戈舞裙，在闪亮的夜总会地板上跺脚，而西班牙最伟大的斗牛士向科德发起决斗挑战。丽塔对科德说：“别那样做，先生。和西班牙最伟大的斗牛士决斗，你是个傻瓜。”
Rita told me that Cord and Tina's honeymoon was filmed right here in New York, which surprised me. I really thought they went to Spain. Rita told me that she performed her flamenco dance in the morning and then they broke for lunch. She was in the One Life to Live cafeteria and Tina waved her over to her table. Rita had lunch with Tina.
丽塔告诉我科德和蒂娜的蜜月是在纽约拍的，这让我很惊讶。我真以为他们去了西班牙。丽塔告诉我她早上跳了弗拉门戈舞，然后他们就去吃午饭了。她在《只此一生》的食堂里，蒂娜挥手让她去自己的桌子。丽塔和蒂娜一起吃了午饭。
She said Tina was very sweet, but all she talked about was her love for Smokey Robinson. Tina fell in love with Smokey Robinson in real life. She drove a wedge between Smokey and his wife, and left the show so that she you could move to Los Angeles and be with Smokey.
她说蒂娜很甜，但她谈论的全是她对史摩基·罗宾逊的爱。蒂娜在现实生活中爱上了史摩基·罗宾逊。她在史摩基和他妻子之间横插一脚，离开了剧组，这样她就能搬到洛杉矶和史摩基在一起。
I'd read that in the Soap Opera Digest, but it was thrilling to hear it from someone who knows the whole story. Later I was working at the cash register, and Stephanie, one of the managers, told me that her friend, Carol, was the person responsible for re-casting on One Life to Live, replacing the old Tina with the new Tina. I told Stephanie that I liked the new Tina. And she said, "Well, I'll tell my friend Carol. She'll be happy to hear it."
我在《肥皂剧文摘》上读到过这个，但从知道整个故事的人口中听到还是很令人激动。后来我在收银台工作，斯蒂芬妮，其中一位经理，告诉我她的朋友卡罗尔是负责《只此一生》选角的人，用新蒂娜取代了旧蒂娜。我告诉斯蒂芬妮我喜欢新蒂娜。她说：“好吧，我会告诉我朋友卡罗尔的。她会很高兴听到的。”
Then Michael, another one of the managers, got involved, and told me he has been on One Life to Live seven times. He played Clint Buchanan's lawyer five years ago when half the Buchanan family was on trial for the murder of Mitch Laurence. Michael knows Victoria Buchanan personally, and said she's just as sweet and caring in real life as she is on the show. He said that Clint tends to keep to himself and that Bo is a lot of fun.
然后迈克尔，另一位经理，也加入了进来，告诉我他已经在《只此一生》里出现过七次了。五年前，当布坎南家族的一半人在为米奇·劳伦斯的谋杀案受审时，他扮演了克林特·布坎南的律师。迈克尔私下认识维多利亚·布坎南，说她在现实生活中和剧中一样甜美体贴。他说克林特倾向于独处，而博很有趣。
I can't believe I'm hearing these things. I know people who know Tina, Cord, Clint, and Vicky. I'm honing in. I'm getting closer. I can feel it.
我不敢相信我听到了这些事。我认识认识蒂娜、科德、克林特和维基的人。我正在接近。我越来越近了。我能感觉到。
Today, a child told Santa that he wanted his dead father back and a complete set of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles. Everyone loves those turtles. A child came to Santa this morning and his mother said, "All right, Jason. All right. Tell Santa what you want. Tell him what you want." Jason said, "I want Proctin and Gamble to stop animal testing." The mother said, "Procter, Jason. That's Procter & Gamble. And what do they do to animals? Do they torture animals, Jason? Is that what they do?" Jason said, "Yes, they torture." He was maybe six years old.
今天，一个孩子告诉圣诞老人他想要他死去的父亲回来，还有一套完整的忍者神龟。每个人都喜欢那些神龟。今天早上一个孩子来到圣诞老人面前，他的母亲说：“好了，杰森。好了。告诉圣诞老人你想要什么。告诉他你想要什么。”杰森说：“我想要宝洁公司停止动物实验。”母亲说：“宝洁，杰森。是宝洁公司。他们对动物做了什么？他们虐待动物吗，杰森？那是他们做的吗？”杰森说：“是的，他们虐待。”他大概只有六岁。
Tonight a man proposed to his girlfriend in Santa house number five. Santa asked what he wanted for Christmas and he pulled a ring out of his pocket and said that he wanted this woman to be his wife. The Photo Elf got choked up and started crying.
今晚有个男人在圣诞老人五号屋向女朋友求婚。圣诞老人问他圣诞节想要什么，他从口袋里掏出一枚戒指说，他想要这个女人成为他的妻子。拍照精灵哽咽了，开始哭。
I got a new haircut and a few people complimented me, but it didn't register. I spend all day lying to people, saying, "You look so pretty," and "Santa can't wait to visit with you. You're all he talks about. It's just not Christmas without you. You're Santa's favorite person in the entire tri-state area."
我剪了个新发型，几个人夸我，但我没当回事。我整天都在对人撒谎，说：“你看上去真漂亮，”还有“圣诞老人迫不及待想见你。他整天都在谈论你。没有你圣诞节都不算圣诞节。你是圣诞老人在这片三州地区最喜欢的人。”
Sometimes I lay it on really thick. "Aren't you the princess of Rongovia? Santa said that a beautiful princess was coming to visit him. He said she would be wearing a red dress and that she was very pretty, but not stuck up or two-faced. That's you isn't it?" I lay it on and the parents mouth the words, "Thank you," and "Good job."
有时我说得很肉麻。“你不是荣戈维亚的公主吗？圣诞老人说一位美丽的公主会来看他。他说她会穿着红色的裙子，而且她非常漂亮，但不傲慢，也不虚伪。那是你，对吧？”我这么说着，父母口型同步着“谢谢”和“干得好”。
To one child I said, "You're a model, aren't you?" The girl was maybe six years old and she said, "Yes, I model, but I also act. I just got a second callback for a Fisher Price commercial." The girl's mother said, "You may recognize Katelyn from the My First Sony campaign. She's pictured on the box." I said, "Yes, of course." All I do is lie, and that has made me immune to compliments.
对一个孩子我说：“你是个模特，对吧？”那个女孩大约六岁，她说：“是的，我是模特，但我也会演戏。我刚拿到了费雪玩具广告的第二次试镜通知。”女孩的母亲说：“你可能从‘我的第一台索尼’广告活动中认出凯特琳。包装盒上就是她。”我说：“是的，当然。”我所做的只是撒谎，这让我对赞美产生了免疫力。
This afternoon, I was stuck being Photo Elf for Santa Santa. I don't know his real name. No one does. During most days, there's a slow period when you sit around the house and talk to Santa. And most of them are nice guys, and we sit around and laugh. But Santa Santa takes himself a bit too seriously. I asked him where he lives, Brooklyn or Manhattan. And he said, "Why, I live at the North Pole with Mrs. Claus." I asked what he does the rest of the year and he said, "I make toys for all the children." Santa Santa sits and waves and jingles his bell sash when no one is there. He actually recited "The Night Before Christmas," and it was just the two of us in the house. No children, just us. He says, "Oh little elf, little elf. Straighten up those mantel toys for Santa." I reminded him that I have a name, Crumpet, and then I straightened up the stuffed animals. "Oh little elf, little elf. Bring Santa a throat lozenge." So I brought him a lozenge.
今天下午，我被迫给圣诞老人的圣诞老人当拍照精灵。我不知道他的真名。没人知道。在大多数日子里，总有清闲的时候，你会坐在屋子里和圣诞老人聊天。大多数人都是好人，我们坐在一起大笑。但那个圣诞老人把自己看得太严肃了。我问他住哪，布鲁克林还是曼哈顿。他说：“噢，我住在北极，和圣诞奶奶在一起。”我问他一年中剩下的时间做什么，他说：“我给所有的孩子们做玩具。”当没人时，他坐着挥手，摇晃着他的铃铛腰带。他竟然背诵了《圣诞前夜》，房子里只有我们两个。没有孩子，只有我们。他说：“噢，小精灵，小精灵。把圣诞老人的壁炉玩具整理好。”我提醒他我有名字，叫松饼，然后我整理了填充动物。“噢，小精灵，小精灵。给圣诞老人拿一颗润喉糖。”所以我给他拿了一颗。
Santa Santa has an elaborate little act for the children. He'll talk to them and give a hearty chuckle and ring his bells. And then he asks them to name their favorite Christmas carol. Most of them say "Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer." Santa then asks if they'll sing it for him. The children are shy and don't want to sing out loud. So Santa Santa says, "Oh little elf, little elf. Help young Brenda here sing that favorite carol of hers." Then I have to stand there and sing "Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer," which I hate.
那个圣诞老人有一套复杂的小把戏来应付孩子们。他会跟他们聊天，发出爽朗的笑声，摇晃他的铃铛。然后他让他们说出他们最喜欢的圣诞颂歌。大多数人说《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》。圣诞老人然后问他们是否愿意为他唱出来。孩子们害羞，不想大声唱。所以圣诞老人说：“噢，小精灵，小精灵。帮帮小布伦达唱她最喜欢的那首歌吧。”然后我得站在那里唱《红鼻子驯鹿鲁道夫》，我讨厌这首歌。
Late in the afternoon, a child said she didn't know what her favorite Christmas carol was. Santa Santa suggested "Away in a Manger." The girl agreed to it but didn't want to sing because she didn't know the words. Santa Santa said, "Oh little elf, little elf. Come sing 'Away in a Manger' for us." It didn't seem fair that I should have to solo. So I told Santa that I didn't know the words. Santa Santa said, "Of course you know the words. Come now. Sing." So I sang it the way Billie Holiday might have sang if she had put out a Christmas album.
傍晚时分，一个孩子说她不知道她最喜欢的圣诞颂歌是什么。圣诞老人建议唱《远离马槽》。女孩同意了，但不想唱，因为她不会词。圣诞老人说：“噢，小精灵，小精灵。来为我们唱一首《远离马槽》吧。”我觉得让我独唱不公平。所以我告诉圣诞老人我不会词。圣诞老人说：“你当然会词。来吧。唱。”所以我唱了起来，是用如果比莉·哈乐黛出了圣诞专辑可能会唱出的那种风格。
Away in a manger, no crib for a bed, the little Lord Jesus lay down his sweet head.
远离马槽，没有婴儿床做床，小主耶稣放下他甜美的头。
Santa Santa did not allow me to finish.
那个圣诞老人没让我唱完。
This evening I was sent to be a Photo Elf in house number two. The camera is hidden in the fireplace, and I take the picture by pressing a button on the end of a cord. Most elves will hold up a stuffed animal over the fireplace and say, "Look at my little animal friend and smile." Oftentimes, the parent will settle the child on Santa's lap and then start grooming. I've seen mothers pull cans of hairspray from their pocketbooks and spray the child's hair as if Santa were a false prop made out of cement. Hairspray shoots into Santa's eyes, and he winces in pain.
今晚我被派到二号房当拍照精灵。照相机藏在壁炉里，我按一下绳子末端的按钮就拍照。大多数精灵会把一个毛绒玩具举在壁炉上方说：“看着我的小动物朋友，笑一笑。”通常，家长会把孩子安顿在圣诞老人膝盖上，然后开始打理孩子。我见过母亲从手提包里掏出发胶罐，朝孩子的头发喷，就像圣诞老人只是一个水泥做的假道具。发胶射进圣诞老人的眼睛里，他痛得倒吸一口凉气。
Once a child starts crying, it's all over. The parents had planned to send these pictures as cards or store them away until the child is grown and can lie, claiming to remember the experience. Tonight I saw a woman slap and shake her crying child. She yelled, "Rachel, get on that man's lap and smile, or I'll give you something to cry about." Then she sat Rachel on Santa's lap, and I took the picture, which supposedly means, on paper, that everything is exactly the way it's supposed to be, that everything is snowy and wonderful. It's not about the child or Santa or Christmas or anything, but the parents' idea of a world they can not make work for them.
一旦孩子开始哭，一切就完了。家长本打算把这些照片作为贺卡寄出，或者存起来，直到孩子长大后能撒谎，假装记得这段经历。今晚我看到一个女人扇了她哭闹的孩子一巴掌并摇晃她。她大喊：“瑞秋，坐到那个男人膝盖上笑，不然我就让你有理由哭。”然后她把瑞秋放在圣诞老人膝盖上，我拍了照，这意味着，在纸面上，一切都按照它应该的样子，一切都是冰雪覆盖且美好的。这无关孩子、圣诞老人或圣诞节或任何事，而关乎家长心目中那个他们无法为自己创造的完美世界。
David Sedaris' "SantaLand Diaries" are published in his book Barrel Fever. His forthcoming book of stories is called Naked.
大卫·塞达里斯的《圣诞乐园日记》收录在他书《桶里发烧》中。他即将出版的故事集叫《赤裸》。
Act Three, Christmas Freud. Well, on the Upper East Side of New York City, the upscale department store Barney's has chosen an odd tactic for its Christmas decorations. Namely, they don't refer to Christmas. It's like an odd-- you know, you've got to respect that kind of contrarian streak. Instead, each of their department store windows is dedicated to different famous people of the twentieth century, filled with memorabilia, pictures, video monitors, all sorts of images and colors and lights. The subjects of the windows? Frank Sinatra, the beat poets, great blonds of the 20th century, Martin Luther King, and Sigmund Freud.
第三幕，圣诞弗洛伊德。嗯，在纽约市的上东区，高档百货商店巴尼百货为他们的圣诞装饰选择了一个奇怪的策略。也就是说，他们不提圣诞节。这就像一个奇怪的——你知道，你不得不尊重那种反其道而行的劲头。相反，他们的每一个百货橱窗都致力于纪念不同的二十世纪名人，装满了纪念品、照片、视频监视器，各种图像、颜色和灯光。这些橱窗的主题是谁？弗兰克·辛纳屈、垮掉派诗人、20世纪伟大的金发女郎、马丁·路德·金和西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。
Only one of these windows has a live human being in it, and it's the Freud window. The human being is a 30-ish bearded actor named David Rakoff.
这些橱窗中只有一个里面有活人，那就是弗洛伊德的橱窗。那个人是一个30多岁、留着胡子的演员，名叫大卫·拉科夫。
I am the ghost of Christmas subconscious. I am the anti-Santa. I am Christmas Freud. People tell me what they wish for. I tell them the ways their wishes are unhealthy or wished for in error. My impersonation merely involves me sitting in a chair either writing or reading The Times or The Interpretation of Dreams every Saturday and Sunday until Christmas.
我是圣诞潜意识的幽灵。我是反圣诞老人。我是圣诞弗洛伊德。人们告诉我他们想要什么。我告诉他们他们的愿望是不健康的，或者是不该许的。我的模仿仅仅涉及我坐在椅子上，在圣诞节前的每个周六和周日写字或阅读《时报》或《梦的解析》。
I sit in a mock study facing Madison Avenue at 61st Street. My study has the requisite chair and couch. It's also equipped with a motorized track on which a video camera-wielding baby carriage travels back and forth, a slide projector, a large revolving black and white spiral, two hanging torsos, and about 10 video monitors that play Freud-related text and images.
我坐在一个面向麦迪逊大道61街的模拟书房里。我的书房有必备的椅子和沙发。它还配备了一条电动轨道，上面有一辆挥舞摄像机的婴儿车来回移动、一台幻灯片放映机、一个巨大的旋转黑白螺旋、两个悬挂的躯干，以及大约10个播放弗洛伊德相关文字和图像的视频监视器。
When I sit down in the chair for the first time, I'm suddenly horrified at the humiliation of this. And I have no idea how I'm going to get through four weekends sitting here on display. And this role raises unprecedented performance questions for me. For starters, should I act as though I had no idea there were people outside my window? I opt for covering my embarrassment with a kind of Olympian humorlessness. If they want twinkles, that's Santa's department.
当我第一次坐在那把椅子上时，我突然对这种羞辱感感到恐惧。我不知道我怎么能在这里坚持四个周末让人观看。这个角色为我提出了前所未有的表演问题。首先，我是不是应该装作不知道窗外有人？我选择用一种奥林匹斯式的冷漠幽默来掩盖我的尴尬。如果他们想要闪烁，那是圣诞老人的部门。
I am gnawed at by two fears. One, that I'm being upstaged by Linda Evans' wig in the blonds window. And two, that a car will suddenly lose control, come barreling through my window, and kill me, an ignoble end to be sure, a life given in the service of retail.
我被两种恐惧所折磨。第一，我被金发女郎橱窗里琳达·埃文斯的假发抢了风头。第二，一辆车会突然失控，冲进我的橱窗，把我撞死，这无疑是一个卑微的结局，一个为零售业牺牲的生命。
Sometimes, for no clear reason, entire crowds make the collective decision not to breach a respectful six foot distance from the window. Other times, they crowd in, attempting to read what I'm writing over my shoulder. I thank God for my illegible handwriting.
有时，出于某种不明确的原因，人群会集体决定不打破窗户前六英尺的礼貌距离。其他时候，他们会挤进来，试图看清我在肩头写什么。我感谢上帝给了我一手潦草的字迹。
Easily half the people have no idea who I'm supposed to be. They wave, as if Freud was Garfield the cat. Others snap photos. The waves are the kind of tiny juvenile hand crunches one gives to something either impossibly young and tiny or adorably fluffy. "Oh, look. It's Freud. Isn't he just the cutest thing you ever saw? Aw, I just want to bundle him up and take him home."
至少有一半人根本不知道我应该是谁。他们挥手，好像弗洛伊德是猫咪加菲。其他人拍照。那些挥手是那种当你面对某种不可思议的幼小、微小或可爱毛茸茸的东西时给出的那种幼稚的手势。“噢，看。是弗洛伊德。他不是你见过最可爱的吗？唉，我真想把他裹起来带回家。”
There are also the folks who are more concerned with whether or not I'm real. This I find particularly laughable, since where on Earth would they make mannequins that look so Jewish? My friend David came up yesterday, and was writing down what people were saying outside. "He really looks like him, only younger." "Hey, that's a real guy." "He just turned the page. Is he allowed to do that?" "Who is that, Professor Higgins?"
也有人更关心我是否真实。我觉得这尤其可笑，因为他们在世界上哪里能制造出看起来这么犹太的模特？我朋友大卫昨天来了，记下了人们在外面说的话。“他真的很像他，只是更年轻。”“嘿，那是真人。”“他刚翻页。他能那样做吗？”“那是谁，希金斯教授？”
If psychoanalysis was late 19th century secular Judaism's way of finding spiritual meaning in a post-religious world and retail is the late 20th century's way of finding spiritual meaning in a post-religious world, what does it mean that I'm impersonating the father of psychoanalysis in a store window to commemorate a religious holiday? In the window, I fantasize about starting an entire Christmas Freud movement. Christmas Freuds everywhere, providing grownups and children alike with the greatest gift of all, insight.
如果精神分析是19世纪末世俗犹太教在后宗教世界寻找精神意义的方式，而零售业是20世纪末在后宗教世界寻找精神意义的方式，那么我为了纪念一个宗教节日而在商店橱窗里模仿精神分析之父意味着什么？在橱窗里，我幻想发起一场完整的圣诞弗洛伊德运动。到处都是圣诞弗洛伊德，为大人和孩子提供最伟大的礼物：洞察力。
In department stores across America, people leave display window couches snifflingly and meaningfully whispering, "Thank you, Christmas Freud," shaking his hand fervently, their holiday angst, if not dispelled, at least brought into starker relief. Christmas Freud on the cover of Cigar Aficionado magazine. Christmas Freud on Friends. People grumbling that-- here it is, not even Thanksgiving, and already stores are running ads with Christmas Freud's face asking the question, "What do women want for Christmas?"
在美国各地的百货商店，人们从橱窗里的沙发上下来，抽泣着、意味深长地低声说：“谢谢你，圣诞弗洛伊德，”热切地握着他的手，他们的节日焦虑即使没有消除，至少也变得更加鲜明了。《雪茄客》杂志封面的圣诞弗洛伊德。《老友记》里的圣诞弗洛伊德。人们抱怨说——这不，还没到感恩节，商店里已经到处都是圣诞弗洛伊德脸庞的广告，问着同一个问题：“女人们圣诞节想要什么？”
If it caught on, all the stores would have to compete. Bergdorf Goodman would leap into action with a C. G. Jung window, a near-perfect simulation of a bear cave. While the Melanie Klein window at Niketown would have them lined up six deep. And neighborhood groups would object to the saliva and constant bell ringing in the Baby Gap's B. F. Skinner window.
如果这流行起来，所有的商店都得竞争。波道夫·古德曼百货会跳出来做一个卡尔·荣格橱窗，一个近乎完美的熊洞模拟。而耐克店里的梅兰妮·克莱因橱窗会让人们排起六层深的队。社区团体也会反对盖普婴儿店的B.F.斯金纳橱窗里产生的口水和不断的摇铃声。
There's an unspeakably handsome man outside the window right now, writing something down. I hope it's his phone number. How do I indicate to the woman in the fur coat, in benevolent Christmas Freud fashion, of course, to get the hell out of the way? Then again, how does one cruise someone through a department store window? Should I press my own phone number up against the glass, like some polar bear in the zoo holding up a sign reading, "Help! I'm being held prisoner"?
此时此刻，窗外有一个帅得无法形容的男人正在记什么东西。我希望那是他的电话号码。我该如何以圣诞弗洛伊德那种仁慈的方式，让那个穿皮草大衣的女人让路呢？再说，一个人怎么能透过百货公司的橱窗去搭讪别人？我是不是该把我的电话号码按在玻璃上，就像动物园里的北极熊拿着写着“救命！我被囚禁了”的牌子一样？
One day, I come up to the store for a photo op for a news story about the holiday windows of New York. It is my 32nd birthday. I am paired with a little girl named Sasha. It's her birthday, as well. She is turning 10. She is strikingly beautiful and appears in the upcoming Howard Stern movie. She's to be my patient for the photographers.
有一天，我来到商店参加一个关于纽约节日橱窗的新闻故事的照片拍摄。那是我的32岁生日。我和一个叫萨莎的小女孩配对。这也是她的生日。她要满10岁了。她美得惊人，即将在霍华德·斯特恩的电影中露面。她是摄影师的病人。
In true psychoanalytic fashion, I make her lie down and face away from me. I explain to her a little bit about Freud, and we play a word association game. I say, "Center." She responds, "Of attention." I ask her her dreams and aspirations for this, the coming 11th year of her life. "To make another feature and to have my role on One Life to Live continue." She sells every word she says to me, smiling with both sets of teeth, her gem-like eyes glittering. She might as well be saying, "crunchy" the entire time. But she is charming. I experience extreme countertransference.
用真正的精神分析方式，我让她躺下，背对着我。我向她解释了一点弗洛伊德的知识，我们玩了一个词语联想游戏。我说：“中心。”她回答：“关注。”我问她对这即将到来的第11个年头的梦想和抱负。“再演一部大片，继续我在《只此一生》里的角色。”她对我说的每一个字都像是在推销，两排牙齿微笑着，像宝石一样的眼睛闪闪发光。她整段时间说“脆脆的”效果也一样。但她很迷人。我经历了强烈的移情。
I read a bit from The Interpretation of Dreams to her. "Is this boring?" I ask. "Oh, no. It's relaxing. I've been working since 5 o'clock this morning. Keep going." Even though her eyes are closed, she senses the light from the news cameras on her. She curls towards it like a plant and clutches her dolly in a startlingly un-childlike manner. The glass of the window fairly fogs up.
我给她读了一点《梦的解析》。“这无聊吗？”我问。“哦，不。这很放松。我从今天早上5点就开始工作了。继续。”尽管她闭着眼睛，但她能感觉到新闻摄像机的光打在她身上。她像植物一样向它蜷缩，以一种惊人的非孩子气姿态抓着她的洋娃娃。橱窗的玻璃几乎都要起雾了。
My photo op with Sasha leads me to the decision to start seeing patients throughout my stint. I'm simply not man enough to sit exposed in a window doing nothing. It's too humiliating and too boring. My patients are all people I know. Perhaps it's because the couch faces away from both the street and myself that the sessions are surprisingly intimate. But it's more than that. The window is, weirdly enough, very cozy, more like a children's hideaway than a fish bowl. Patients seemed to relax immediately upon lying down.
我和萨莎的合影让我决定在我的驻留期间开始接诊病人。我根本不是那种能坐在橱窗里什么都不做的男人。那太羞辱人，也太无聊了。我的病人都是我认识的人。也许是因为沙发背对着街道和我也背对着它，所以治疗过程出奇地亲密。但这不仅仅如此。这个橱窗奇怪地非常舒适，更像是一个孩子的藏身处，而不是一个鱼缸。病人在躺下后似乎立刻放松了。
T. beings the session laughing at the artifice, and ends it actually crying on the sofa. Christmas Freud is prepared and hands him a handkerchief. J. has near-crippling tendinitis and wears huge, padded orthopedic boots. The people watching think it's a fashion statement. She wears a dress from Loehmann's, but I treat her anyway. G., a journalist likes to talk with children and write about them. Perhaps that's why his shirt is irregularly buttoned.
T. 开始治疗时嘲笑这种虚假，最后却在沙发上哭了起来。圣诞弗洛伊德准备好了，递给他一块手帕。J. 有近乎残废的肌腱炎，穿着巨大的加厚矫形靴。人们看着以为那是时尚宣言。她穿着从Loehmann's买来的裙子，但我还是治疗她。G. 是个记者，喜欢跟孩子交谈并写他们。也许这就是为什么他的衬衫扣子扣得乱七八糟。
I'm told that a woman outside the window wondered aloud if I was an actual therapist. I suppose there must be one in this town who would jeopardize his or her credibility in that way. I've scheduled our next session for the window at Barney's. I hope that's OK. Huh, you seem really resistant. Do you want to talk about that?
我听说橱窗外有个女人纳闷我到底是不是真正的治疗师。我想这个城市里一定有一个会冒着信誉受损风险这么做的人。我已经把我们的下一次治疗预约在了巴尼百货的橱窗里。我希望那没问题。嗯，你看起来真的很抵触。你想谈谈那个吗？
A journalist is doing a story on the windows for The Times. He asks me if this is a dream come true. Well, it is a dream. "It's logical," I reply. "One of my parents is a psychiatrist. And the other one is a department store window." He doesn't laugh at my joke, but it's half true. One of my parents is a psychiatrist. The other is an MD who also does psychotherapy.
一位记者正在为《时报》做一个关于橱窗的故事。他问我这是不是美梦成真。嗯，这确实是个梦。“这很符合逻辑，”我回答。“我的父母一个是精神科医生。另一个是一个百货公司橱窗。”他没笑我的笑话，但这半真半假。我的父母一个是精神科医生。另一个是也做心理治疗的医学博士。
I've been in therapy myself, for seven years. The difference between seeing a shrink and being a shrink is not only less pronounced than I imagined it might be, it feels intoxicating. When my own therapist of seven years says, "I have a fantasy of coming by the window and being treated by you," I think, "Of course you do." I feel finally and blissfully victorious.
我自己也做了七年治疗。看精神医生和当精神医生之间的区别不仅比我想象的要小，而且感觉让人陶醉。当我自己的七年治疗师说：“我有一种想来到窗前，接受你治疗的幻想，”我想，“你当然有。”我觉得自己终于获得了幸福的胜利。
My father tells me a dream he had in which I have essentially analyzed and exposed him. It's the only indication I've gotten from him so far that he is anything other than amused by what is, basically, a mockery of what he does. In a certain sense, I'm not just aping my father and my mother but also, in a way, their father, the man who spawned their profession.
我父亲告诉我他做的一个梦，梦里我基本上分析并揭穿了他。这是他目前为止给我的唯一迹象，表明他除了觉得这基本上是对他所做之事的嘲讽外，对他来说什么都不是。在某种意义上，我不只是在模仿我的父母，而且在某种程度上，也是在模仿他们的父亲，那个开创了他们职业生涯的人。
And when I sit there, a patient on my couch, pipe in my mouth, listening, it feels so perfect. Like any psychiatrist's kid, I know enough from growing up and from my own years on the couch to ask open-ended questions, to let the silences play themselves out or not, to say gently, "Our time is up," after 45 minutes. The charade feels real, the conclusion of an equation years in the making.
当我坐在那里，沙发上躺着病人，嘴里叼着烟斗，倾听着，感觉太完美了。像任何精神科医生的孩子一样，我知道成长过程和在沙发上躺了几年后学到的东西，足够问开放式问题，让沉默自己消解与否，在45分钟后温和地说：“时间到了。”这场闹剧感觉真实，是一场延续多年方程的终结。
Even the media coverage for this escapade is extensive and strange. People from newspapers and television are asking me deep questions about the holiday, the nature of alienation at this time of year, things like that, as though I actually was Freud. It's disconcerting because, with very little effort, I could be drunk with the power. But it also points out the O. Henry "Gift of the Magi" quality of it all. The media is so desperate for any departure from the usual holiday stories they have to turn out, they come flocking. And yet, the public doesn't really even want to read about the holiday in the first place. It's like trying to jazz up a meal nobody wants to eat anyway.
甚至媒体对这场闹剧的报道也是广泛而奇怪的。来自报纸和电视的人问我关于节日的深奥问题，关于一年中这个时段异化本质的问题，诸如此类，好像我真的是弗洛伊德一样。这很令人困惑，因为稍微努力一点，我就可能被这种权力冲昏头脑。但这也指出了这一切中欧·亨利式的《麦琪的礼物》的品质。媒体太渴望任何对他们必须炮制的节日故事的偏离了，他们蜂拥而至。然而，公众根本不想阅读关于这个节日的内容。这就像试图给没人想吃的饭菜调味。
I get a call from the store that Allen Ginsberg might be in the beats window on Sunday. And if he wants to, would I speak to him? "I have no sway over Mr. Ginsberg. But if he has something he would like to talk about, I'm certainly available," I tell them. Not entirely true. I'm pretty well booked.
商店给我打来电话，说艾伦·金斯伯格周日可能会在垮掉派橱窗里。如果他愿意，我能和他说话吗？“我对金斯伯格先生没有影响力。但如果他有什么想谈的话，我当然可以提供时间，”我告诉他们。这不完全是真的。我已经排满了。
The whole Allen Ginsberg thing depresses me a bit. Then again, if he can see it as a cosmic joke, why can't I? I feel indignant and very territorial. Impostors only. No real ones in the window. Anyway, it's moot. He doesn't show up.
整个艾伦·金斯伯格的事让我有点沮丧。但再说一次，如果他能把它看作一个宇宙玩笑，我为什么不能？我感到愤怒且非常领地意识。只限冒名顶替者。橱窗里不允许真的。反正，这也不讨论了。他没出现。
There is a street fair outside that teams to have brought a decidedly scarier type of spectator. They are like the crowd at a carnival, and I'm the dog-faced boy. A grown woman sticks her tongue out at me. Later, during a session, a man in his 50s presses his nose up against the window, getting grease on the glass, presses his ears up to hear, and screams things at me I cannot hear.
窗外有一个街头集市，似乎带来了一种更可怕的观众。他们就像嘉年华的人群，而我是那个狗面男孩。一个成年女人冲我吐舌头。后来，在治疗期间，一个50多岁的男人把鼻子压在窗玻璃上，在玻璃上留下油迹，用耳朵贴着窗户听，并对我尖叫我听不清的话。
When I leave after each stint, I put up a little glass sign that reads, "Freud will be back soon." It's like a warning, the post-modern version of "Christ is coming. Repent." Freud will be back soon, whether you like it or not. Freud will be back soon. Stop deceiving yourselves.
每次工作结束我离开时，我会挂出一个写着“弗洛伊德很快就会回来”的小玻璃牌。这就像一个警告，后现代版的“基督即将到来。忏悔吧。”弗洛伊德很快就会回来，无论你喜欢与否。弗洛伊德很快就会回来。停止欺骗你们自己吧。
In the affluent downtown neighborhood in Toronto in which I was raised, someone had spraypainted on a wall "Mao lives," to which someone else had added, "here?" My window is a haven in Midtown. I can sit there unmindful of the crush in the aisles of the store, the hour badly spent over gifts thoughtlessly and desperately bought. As I sit there I hear the songs that play for the display one window over, the blonds of the 20th century. Doris Day singing "Once I Had a Secret Love." Mae West singing "My Old Flame." Marlene Dietrich singing "Falling in Love Again. As I listen, I feel that they're really referring to my window, to Freud. Every time they come up on the repeating tape, I find them almost unbearably poignant, with all their talk of clandestine love, erotic fixation, and painfully hidden romantic agenda.
在我成长的多伦多富裕市中心社区，有人在墙上喷涂了“毛主席万岁”，另一个人加上了“……在这儿？”我的橱窗是城中区的一个避风港。我可以坐在那里，不顾商店走道里的拥挤，那些为了买到考虑不周和绝望购买的礼物而虚度的时间。当我坐在那里，我听到了给隔壁橱窗（20世纪金发女郎）播放的歌曲，多丽丝·戴唱着“我曾有过一段秘密恋情。”梅·韦斯特唱着“我的旧情人。”玛琳·黛德丽唱着“再次坠入爱河。”当我听着的时候，我觉得他们真的是指我的橱窗，指弗洛伊德。每次他们在循环磁带中出现时，我都觉得它们几乎令人难以忍受的凄美，谈论着秘密恋情、色情固定思维和痛苦隐藏的浪漫议程。
But they might also just as easily be referring to this time of year, with the aching sadness and loneliness that seems to imbue everything. Where is that perfect object, that old flame, that secret love that eludes us? Unfindable, unpurchaseable.
但它们也可能同样容易指代一年中的这个时刻，那种似乎浸透一切的凄凉悲伤和孤独。那个完美的对象在哪里，那个旧情人，那个逃避我们的秘密恋情在哪里？不可寻找，不可购买。
This is my final weekend as Christmas Freud, and I'm starting to feel bereft in anticipation of having to take down my shingle. I started off as a monkey on display and have wound up uncomfortably caught between joking and deadly serious, a persona that seems laughable at times, fated for me at others. I know this will pass, but for now I want nothing more than to continue to sit in my chair, someone on the couch, and to ask them, with real concern, "So tell me, how's everything?"
这是我作为圣诞弗洛伊德的最后一个周末，我开始因为不得不摘下招牌而感到孤苦。我开始时是一个被展示的猴子，最终却不安地夹在玩笑和极度严肃之间，这个角色有时看起来可笑，有时又是我的宿命。我知道这终将过去，但目前，我只想坐在椅子上，沙发上有人，然后怀着真正的关心问他们：“那么告诉我，一切都好吗？”
[MUSIC - "CHRISTMAS FREUD CAROLING," THE FORMERLY KNOWN AS FAMILY]
[音乐 - “圣诞弗洛伊德颂歌”，原名为“家庭”组合]
You know, I think we have time for one more act.
你知道，我想我们还有时间再演一幕。
Where's [? Jennan's ?] at?
詹南在哪儿？
See what it says on the box there.
看看盒子上写着什么。
It just says, "Dad."
上面只写着，“爸爸”。
For Daddy.
给爸爸。
Oh, I was a good boy.
哦，我以前是个好男孩。
Daddy was a good boy. He got something.
爸爸是个好男孩。他得到了什么东西。
It's 1966. John's family taped everything, all the time, he says, including this Christmas when he was three.
那是1966年。他说，约翰的家人一直都在录像，包括这个他三岁时的圣诞节。
Wowee.
哇哦。
Look it.
你看。
What are you doing in there?
你在那儿干什么？
Sparky, get out of there. Look at that. Isn't that really sweet?
斯帕基，出来。看那儿。那不是很甜吗？
Oh boy. Look at how nice.
哦天哪。看多棒。
How about that one? Do you like it?
那个怎么样？你喜欢吗？
John is John Connors, a Chicago DJ. He provides a lot of the music for This American Life from his vast and strange record collection. And on this, the third Christmas of his life, he is given exactly the present that he asked for, a close and play record player. This is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. John's mother pulls out her camera to take a picture of him with his presents.
约翰是约翰·康纳斯，芝加哥的一名DJ。他用他广博而怪异的唱片收藏为《美国生活》提供了很多音乐。在他生命中的第三个圣诞节，他得到了他想要的礼物，一台唱片播放机。这是[听不清]。约翰的妈妈拿出相机给他和他的礼物拍照。
Do you like it?
你喜欢吗？
John with his first phonograph.
约翰和他的第一台唱机。
OK, baby. Smile pretty.
好了，宝贝。笑得漂亮点。
Well, now the bulb don't work. Are there any batteries in there?
嗯，现在灯泡不亮了。里面有电池吗？
I just put new batteries in there. What the heck?
我刚放了新电池进去。搞什么鬼？
Don't be spitting on them. You'll have lead poisoning.
别往上面吐口水。你会铅中毒的。
Ah.
啊。
It deteriorates from there.
从那之后就变质了。
Ah, I'm disgusted with these cameras. I should have gotten a nice one from Santa Claus. That's what I should have got.
啊，我对这些相机感到恶心。我本该从圣诞老人那儿得到一个好的。那才是我本该得到的。
This right here? This is what Christmas is all about. Everybody's posed, everybody's ready, everybody's straining to be happy, and everybody has this picture in their heads of the perfect Christmas. And of course, it is never going to be perfect. It's never going to live up to that picture. And so disappointment is built into the very structure of the day.
这个地方吗？这就是圣诞节的全部意义所在。每个人都摆好姿势，每个人都准备好了，每个人都努力变得快乐，每个人脑子里都有那种完美圣诞节的画面。当然，它永远不会完美。它永远无法达到那个画面。所以失望是这一天结构中固有的。
And so the best you can hope for on Christmas-- and I say this as a Jew, somebody who has never celebrated the holiday, which makes me an outside observer, an impartial observer-- the best you can do is to ride the imperfections, hope they don't overtake everybody.
所以你在圣诞节最好的希望就是——我作为一个犹太人说这话，一个从未庆祝过这个节日的人，这让我成了一个局外观察者，一个公正的观察者——你所能做的最好的就是顺应那些不完美，希望它们不会压倒每个人。
In this tape from 1966, John's parents spent a lot of time trying to keep him from destroying a new train set the very first day he gets it.
在这盘1966年的录音带里，约翰的父母花了很多时间试图阻止他在得到新火车模型的第一天就把它拆了。
Half way, John. Half way. Oh!
半路，约翰。半路。噢！
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的说话声]
Three-year-old John runs the train so fast, it always crashes.
三岁的约翰开火车的速度太快了，它总是出轨。
Well, don't turn it so fast, John. John, don't monkey with that.
嗯，别开那么快，约翰。约翰，别摆弄那个。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] over there.
[听不清]在那边。
All day long, a perfect day wavers in and out of focus, for a while wobbling towards disaster. Broken toys, hurt feelings, disappointment, and listing back towards happiness. Our three-year-old DJ puts a 45 of "Winchester Cathedral" in his new record player and runs the trains as fast as he can.
整整一天，完美的一天在焦点内外摇晃，有一阵子摇晃着向灾难倾斜。破碎的玩具、受伤的感情、失望，然后再向幸福倾斜。我们三岁的DJ把他新唱机里的《温彻斯特大教堂》45转唱片放好，然后尽可能快地开动火车。
Our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike.
我们今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。
"Christmas Freud Caroling" by The Formerly Known As Family-- Bill O'Reilly, Kate O'Reilly, [? Colum ?] O'Reilly, and Jenny Magnus.
“圣诞弗洛伊德颂歌”由“曾经被称为家庭”组合表演——比尔·奥莱利、凯特·奥莱利、科伦·奥莱利和珍妮·马格努斯。
For tapes of This American Life, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380.
欲索取《美国生活》录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
Freud will be back soon. Stop deceiving yourselves.
弗洛伊德很快就会回来。停止欺骗你们自己吧。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。